question tout de suite est ce que cette
vidéo va être une vidéo de daron et de
darron moi je pense la question allait
vite répandue oui c'est le cas chaque
parent élève son enfant ses enfants à sa
manière et moi qui suis parent depuis
maintenant un an et demi je dois dire
que ça y est là il ya vraiment plus de
galère je gère au s'occuper d'un bébé
déjà c'est quelque chose mais j'espère
qu'on va pas être confinée c'est quand
tu passes deux mois enfermé h 24 avec
ton bébé c'est clairement une épreuve de
koh lanta a sauf que tu peux pas faire
au bout de 30 jours mais aucun qui
quitte l'aventuré
un bébé de 1 an et demi en général c'est
assez énergique la nôtre pour donner un
ordre d'idée voit la surnomme la tornade
en gros tu peux absolument pas à
détourner le regard de son enfant plus
de une seconde un enfant d'un an et demi
on dirait que sa passion c'est de
prouver tous les jours un moyen
différent se suicider elle veut jouer
avec les rasoirs aspirer langue des
feutres monter sur la table on y sauve
la vie toutes les 30 secondes entre sa
sécurité et le bordel quel fou au bout
d'un moment clairement pas maison que la
transforme
c'est plus chez toi hein tu vis chez le
bébé par exemple de mettre des cash
prizes sinon bah c'est ça l'idée
entièrement le bas la bibliothèque sinon
baltes et ceux ci on a dû installer un
mini open de conflits au mieux de salon
évidemment on a dû mettre des blocs
portes sinon elle va aux toilettes pour
boire évidemment on utilise des bols
munis de ventouses selon elle le fait
quand même
yes au fil des mois ton bébé acquièrent
de nouvelles compétences un peu comme
des attirances aude et profite d'un jeu
vidéo quoi saisir des objets dans qui
pousse marcher parler on va parler dire
quelques mots quoi mais j'avoue que la
première fois où elle m'a regardé
qu'elle m'a dit papa
on va clairement j'étais hyper est mieux
quoi
tu m'appeler papa après futin c'est trop
beau tu sais qui je suis pour toi tu ton
père c'est ça les regarde et lui sait
qui a nom c'est moi papa et lui c'est
qu'il est mon pote camille martha faut
qu'on parle
il paraît que beaucoup font ça au début
en plus elle m'appelle pas pas comme
s'il y avait une suite derrière
alors qu'en fait c'est pas parler donc à
jamais de suite donc j'essaye de lui
répondre mais la discussion tourne vite
en rond
oui oui oui j'écoute non double
décimètre culture beat à ces routes et
cela à l'infini avant d'avoir un enfant
quand je marche dans la rue
chanter un petit peu des petites
chansons dans ma tête ça fait son band
café où mais maintenant que j'ai un
enfant c'est tellement conditionnés dans
la rue je me rends compte que je chante
des trucs genre le pape a tort tués
alors on a fait l'acquisition d'un baby
phone avec ce truc là tu surveilles
performant depuis au pub pas trop loin
quoi alors déjà il ya une option cholot
pour parler directement aux bébés dans
le berceau
[Musique]
et surtout quand tu travailles la nuit
et que tu vois ton bébé sur l'écran
debout dans son lit en infrarouge
c'est clairement un film d'horreur
je sais pas si c'est l'effet infrarouge
qui fait ça mais même le boude ou des
flips et andré avec ce à n'importe quel
objet c'est flippant si les fonds se
révèle comme ça en avant l'admission
l'écran sa copine à me dire je vais
aller la voir
non j'ai pas envie non et vas-y toi
c'est marrant parce que au sein du
couple
tu parle différemment du bébé en
fonction de citer en embrouille ou pas
avec l'autre un exemple la balle est
vraiment trop mignonne aux filles tu
pouvais au moins tu occupais un peu de
ta fille mercy
un autre exemple quand une rencontre aux
câlins donncha norman tu pourrais au
moins la vie à litière de ton chat ouest
ont charmé tous là d'après ses attaches
à quai de nos jours quand le père
s'occupe du bébé
voilà un spécial c'est normal pas besoin
d'une médaille mais à l'époque de nos
parents c'est pas forcément pareil moi
mon père quand il me voit m'occuper de
ma petite qui me dit regardez moi
comment ils s'occupent de ce qu'ongo
celui s et le père du futur c'est le
papa moderne un ace et un peu le monde à
l'envers quand même un pas de mentir
alors que c'est la base quoi j'avoue que
moi au début de ma vie mon père il a dû
remarquer j'étais là quand j'avais 4 ans
limite il disait à ma mère quand notre
fils il est vraiment magnifique ma
chérie vas-y appelle moi il sait parler
d'accord ok tu veux écouter pink floyd à
l'album il ya un match de polo
il ya quand même des points positifs
quand élève un enfant par exemple le
moment où où tu le déposait la crèche
ross avons déconné ou quoi là non mais
vous êtes coincé du cul en fait on fait
des blagues et tout mais élever un
enfant c'est vraiment le truc le plus
magnifique du monde hein c'est pas pour
rien que l'on ait 7 milliards sur terre
et je pense que tu comprends et tu
réalises vraiment le bonheur que c'est à
partir du moment où tu le vis en fait
[Musique]